this is a place for
everyone this is a place if you're just
having questions and no answers this is
a place if you're a designer or an
expert and you're thinking of how your
technology can be more
responsible this is a place if you're an
academic or Civil Society person this is
also a place if you're not adequately
represented like if you feel like
because of your genda your race your
orientation or your ability um you're
finding spaces to find Leverage and
acceptance I think this is a space for
[Music]
you
meeting people has been really wonderful
everyone is lovely everyone is accepting
and inclusive I like that the the
sessions in the morning um set the theme
or the topic or the conversation for the
day and that trickles through to the
lunchtimes with the other participants
and their perspectives given their I
guess professional background and then
that then carries on to the social part
of the evening so the thing that brings
people together here is Passion it's not
skills and it's not background so if
you're passionate about responsibility
ey please
[Music]
apply